[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión nos
vamos a Estados Unidos donde hace cinco
años en Virginia una tragedia simbolizó
El regreso al protagonismo de la extrema
derecha en Estados Unidos durante el
mandato de Donald Trump el 12 de agosto
de 2017 los miembros de unitedright que
reúne a supremacistas blancos miembros
del klux Klan o neonazis pretendían
protestar contra La retirada de la
Estatua de Robert League general durante
la Guerra Civil estadounidense a pesar
del temor de enfrentamientos la
manifestación fue autorizada por un juez
en nombre de la libertad de expresión y
como era de esperarse se produjeron
enfrentamientos con los residentes
locales y activistas anti racistas la
policía acabó interviniendo para separar
a los dos bandos pero los manifestantes
anti racistas volvieron a reunirse A
pocas cal la distancia fue allí donde un
joven activista de la supremacía blanca
James fields condujo su automóvil contra
los manifestantes y luego dio marcha
atrás atropellando a los transeúntes
mató a una joven e hirió a otras 19
personas una hora después del ataque del
presidente Donald Trump dio unas
declaraciones en las cuales Sí condenó
el violento ataque pero criticó a ambos
bandos
condenamos fuertemente esta atroz
violenta muestra de odio y de fanatismo
por parte de ambos lados de ambos lados
sus palabras por supuesto provocaron una
ola de indignación incluso por parte de
sus seguidores
5 años después del trágico ataque se han
curado las heridas de Charles Bill que
ha pasado con las víctimas y los
agresores sigue siendo la extrema
derecha estadounidense una amenaza para
la democracia Esta es la historia
[Música]
estamos en el lugar donde un vehículo
embistió la multitud en un intento de
asesinato en masa
y solo logró asesinar a mi hija
[Música]
era apasionada era firme en su
determinación de hacer del mundo un
lugar mejor
sin embargo era una Don nadie en la
ciudad
no era una activista conocida ni una
figura pública
que era solo una mujer que fue a
protestar con sus amigos ese día
Susan bro visita regularmente este
Memorial improvisado dirigido en la
calle donde el simpatizante neonas y
James Hills envió con su carro a la
multitud provocando la muerte de Heather
fields fue condenado a cadena perpetua
pero cinco años después bro aún lamenta
la muerte de su hija
[Música]
es mi niña todavía pienso en ella a sus
tres años con sus largas colas de
caballo
hay una especie de pesadez en mi corazón
Cuando veo Este muro
debería estar aquí viéndolo con ella y
no viendo un Memorial en su honor
así es la vida
no puedo cambiarla
estoy agradecida por haber podido ser su
mamá por un tiempo
a pesar de su dolor Pro no olvida la
situación general ya la ideología de
odio que alimenta las partes más
extremas de la América blanca
Definitivamente hay fuerzas que trabajan
para provocar controversia y avivar el
odio y el rencor
creen que la gente como yo está
fomentando la victimización y el odio y
la amargura hacia ellos
no estoy diciendo que tengamos que odiar
a los blancos en absoluto
digo que tenemos que trabajar juntos y
dejar de odiarnos
el ataque que acabó con la vida de
Heather tuvo lugar tras la manifestación
denominada y United right unamos la
derecha
[Aplausos]
en la protesta participaron cientos de
neonazis así como miembros del ku klux
Klan y otros grupos de supremacía Blanca
que nació ponían a la decisión de
Charles retirar la Estatua del General
Robert y lee símbolo del pasado
confederado del Estado todavía hay una
hora muy pesada sobre este lugar
la Estatua del confederado fue
finalmente retirada en julio de 2021 y
el nombre del parque cambió a Parque de
la emancipación
hasta hace unos años Yo solía llamar
este lugar la puerta del infierno pero
ahora Estamos sobre los restos de lo que
fue la Estatua del General confederado
Robert League
esa estatua fue la que los trajo aquí
desde miles de kilómetros de distancia
para venir y formar parte de esta
manifestación
arremetían contra los negros los de
bajos ingresos los de fe judía Y por qué
Don caders es el computador de la rama
local de Black lives matter siempre ha
vivido en Virginia y ha visto como el
clima social se ha deteriorado en los
últimos años cree que la elección de
Donald Trump creó las condiciones para
los actos violentos de charlotteville
el cocoxtlán aún existe a diferencia
ahora es que no necesariamente usan
capuchas ya no se avergüenzan desde el
presidente número 45 y desde que
personas como él están en el poder se
sienten alentados Ya no les importa que
se sepa Quiénes son exactamente dijeron
que iba a ser una concentración pacífica
y sin embargo llevaron sus ak-47 sus
ar-15 sus cuchillos sus machetes
[Música]
la noche anterior al ataque los mismos
supremacistas blancos habían marchado
por el campus de la Universidad de
Virginia portando antorchas coreando
consignas racistas y antisemitas el
primunís recuerda haber visto con horror
estas imágenes que evocaban las horas
más oscuras de la historia de Estados
Unidos
cuando me desperté esa mañana del 12 de
agosto y vi las imágenes de la noche
anterior aquí
eso termino de convencerme de ir a la
contramanifestación para estar con mi
comunidad
de ser testigo de lo que iba a suceder
Claro que no nos imaginábamos lo que iba
a pasar
antes de agosto de 2017 Muñiz había
tenido una vida tranquila pero ese día
estaba en primera línea de la protesta
cuando un auto envistió a la multitud
aunque no resultó herida físicamente el
trauma psicológico la acompaña Entonces
es una escena que nunca olvidaré
y por escena me refiero no solo a lo que
vi sino a lo que escuché los sonidos
nunca serán de mi cabeza no soy la misma
persona que era
Tal vez sea mejor persona en algunos
aspectos porque defiende un poco más mis
ideas
pero definitivamente alteró el curso de
mi vida cambió mi trayectoria
tras el ataque Muñiz perdió su trabajo y
ha estado en terapia desde entonces en
su proceso de recuperación El año pasado
se sumó a otras 8 víctimas en una
demanda civil contra los 25
organizadores de la manifestación y
United right
esta era una de las maneras como yo
podía cambiar las cosas
tenía la posibilidad de ser demandante y
de intentar que los organizadores de
esta manifestación rindieran cuentas
ganamos nuestro caso lo que significa
que en teoría nos deben mucho dinero
que seguramente nunca veremos porque no
lo tienen
pero también significa que no pueden
ganarse ese dinero porque sería para
nosotros Así que eso les impide reunir
más gente
entre los condenados se encuentra
Richard Spencer el fundador del
movimiento nacionalista blanco de
extrema derecha all right Así es como
explicó las consignas antisemitas que se
escucharon durante la manifestación
la frase era no nos reemplazarán que era
como decir
no vamos a aceptar la inmigración masiva
o el desplazamiento cultural etcétera
y luego se transformó en los judíos no
nos reemplazarán
se volvió más desagradable y ofensiva
etcétera creo que en ese momento me
acomodé a ese tipo de discurso porque
estaba impresionado por El poder del
movimiento
me decía que éramos tipos duros
el antisemitismo la supremacía blanca la
teoría del Gran reemplazo eran parte de
la ideología del atacante del 12 de
agosto
films incluso había intentado contactar
a Spencer en repetidas ocasiones en las
redes sociales
[Música]
creo que es alguien que me vio como un
Hitler del Siglo 21
como una figura malvada No sé
no tengo ningún tipo de responsabilidad
por sus acciones o responsabilidad moral
sin embargo veo que muchas de estas
manifestaciones de las que fui parte que
incluso creé en cierto modo
se han salido de control y conducen a la
infelicidad y a la fragmentación e
incluso a la violencia
no quiero seguir siendo parte de eso
Aunque parece haber moderado su discurso
su ideología sigue siendo la misma
soy un supremacista blanco
es solo un término como cualquier otro
quiero lo mejor para los descendientes
de europeos y quiero que la cultura
Europea florezca y triunfe
esto es lo que quiero
tras el ataque de 2017 el movimiento
oldright propiamente dicho se disipó un
poco pero la ideología nacionalista
Blanca sigue viva
Charlottesville es una pequeña Ciudad
Universitaria liberal a unos 100
kilómetros al oeste de Richmond que fue
en su día la capital de la confederación
en un estado en el que la segregación
era todavía una realidad hace 60 años
[Música]
el activista de los Derechos civiles va
a esta Iglesia Bautista todos los días
[Música]
Durante los últimos cinco años con la
ayuda del pastor Jerónimo
ha intentado luchar contra la
ignorancias
la supremacía blanca no es más que una
ideología es lo que alguna gente cree no
existe una persona blanca que sea
superior a cualquier otra raza Entonces
como romper esa enseñanza Cómo cambiar
esa mentalidad En eso estamos ahora creo
que eso es lo que hay que hacer para
avanzar
tenemos que luchar no podemos esconder
la cabeza en la arena y actuar como si
no estuviera pasando nada
esas personas siguen estando ahí eso no
quiere decir que haya que estar alerta
pero hay que recordar que aunque el
ambiente se tranquilo hoy es uno
significa que no volverá a pasar quizás
no Mientras yo esté vivo pero hay que
recordar la historia
recordar la historia eso es lo que ha
querido hacer ese a través de 36
fotografías imágenes que El fotógrafo
eligió para mostrar una comunidad
resiliente y golpeada por la violencia
quise darle a Charles Bill una razón
para hablar de lo que pasó una forma de
reflexionar sobre lo que pasó hace cinco
años y también una forma de apropiarse
de la narrativa de lo que pasó hace
cinco años
en cierto modo recuperar la historia y
convertirla en nuestra historia en vez
de que el mundo tenga una imagen
negativa de charlesville
estas fotos muestran a Susan broke cuya
hija murió en el atentado también
addongaders el activista de los Derechos
civiles y la manifestante
no los conoce personalmente pero cada
rostro cuenta una historia
Esta foto fue tomada mientras los
miembros de la comunidad se reunieron
para lamentar la muerte de hater todavía
lo recuerdo muy bien estaba tomando
fotos miré hacia la colina y vivía esta
niña en su cara se puede ver que estaba
confundida y eso fue lo que me llamó la
atención esa es sin duda una de mis 10
mejores fotos de este proyecto
la esperanza es que estas fotos hagan
que se siga hablando del tema
mucho ha cambiado pero mucho sigue
siendo lo mismo la entiendo la gente
tiene que saber y tiene que recordar
y tenemos que seguir hablando de eso
conversando
no hay que evitarlo no hay que sentir
vergüenza de eso ni sentir sin incómodo
porque si uno se siente incómodo es que
hay un problema
hemos quien se mudó a Charles de Nigeria
hace 14 años cree que el caos de 2017
fue un punto de inflexión
la ciudad ha invertido mucho más en el
crecimiento de los negocios locales
pertenecientes a las minorías
han invertido mucho más en vivienda
hay muchos proyectos de vivienda nuevos
y esto es una consecuencia directa de la
presión del 11 y 12 de agosto de 2017
la universidad de Virginia acaba de
elegir un gran monumento en memoria de
los Esclavos Todavía queda mucho trabajo
por hacer pero puedo decirles como
persona negra que vive en
Charlottesville que estamos trabajando
en eso
mucha gente se ha animado a hablar
cuando alguien no está haciendo bien su
trabajo la gente exige que se rindan
cuentas
la gente ahora habla ahora tiene voz
desde el ataque de Charlottesville en
2017 al menos 131 asesinatos han sido
perpetrados por supremacistas blancos en
Estados Unidos y altos funcionarios de
las fuerzas del orden del gobierno de
biden han declarado públicamente que los
supremacistas blancos son ahora la mayor
amenaza doméstica para el país
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Estados Unidos
recordando la tragedia en
Charlottesville que conmocionó a todo el
país y dejó en evidencia las importantes
diferencias raciales que aún persisten
Recuerden que pueden Ingresar a nuestra
página web France 24.com para ver esta
emisión y las anteriores Hasta pronto
[Música]